the big southpaw sean manaya making his
28th start of the season
if he can get that fastball and keep
that fastball 92 94.95
i think that changeup is going to be a
good weapon for him today lost this one
down the right field line foul territory
and cannon hustling over there makes the
catch
for out number one here in the first
one down robert moves to the two spot
today mark canna is not gonna get there
a little seven iron from robert is a
one-out single you know what i've got
more of a lob wedge on that very nice
more action for canna
toward the corner and kenneth has it
he takes ball forward ron dahl's on
again
so i count 25 reaches in 40 plate
appearances
since he came back from the injured list
well that's like little league
strike three call on the inside corner
good pitch there by manaya and the white
sox strand a pair in the top of the
first raynaldo is going to have to be
careful as he navigates through this
lineup he's looked really good ever
since he came back from the bullpen in
in charlotte he has come in and looked
like a different pitcher
harrison leads off for the asp in the
first reaches for that one pokes it foul
so if you put away your fanny pack you
don't think it's in style anymore we're
telling you right now it's wrong
you can hold baseball you know it'll
catch baseballs for you i think i saw a
granola bar in there i mean that thing's
big enough he probably didn't pay for
parking just fold up the buick and stick
it in that that's what i'm saying
harrison just pokes it to right field so
he sort of mastered that swing in that
at-bat
in the hole
mendic has it and then juggles it drops
it everybody's safe so it's gonna be a
hit from our tank
strike three on a fastball outside lopez
did stay there as you said
and he's got his first out there's some
creeping off the bag trying to draw his
attention there's the throw and lopez
has him
romy gonzalez puts the tag down marty
behind gets to second and ronaldo says
see
this is why
you don't mess around with me yeah that
is that is so great
oh boy
little tapper middle infield mendic on
the charge and danny does spin it out in
time
to retire the side great work by ronaldo
lopez so sean manaya back to work
strike three call another good pitch by
sean manaya he painted the inside corner
with andrew vaughn to end the first and
looked like he made the same pitch to
gonzalez here in the second the fish to
hamilton now
he chases a ball away and down he goes
strike three called won an inning by
sean manaya strikes out the side two of
them looking ph for oakland is jed lowry
and he smokes this one
left center field and that is over the
head of luis robert
a booming double for jed lowry opening
up the bottom of the second inning
one and two
on canna
oh yeah paint job on the outside corner
one gone good afternoon good evening and
good night with one down it's
left-handed hitting tony kemp
yep slaps one down the left-field line
fair ball
lowry's gonna score kemp's racing for
second the ball still rolling around
and now kemp's gonna try for third and
he is safe
tony kemp
showing off the wheels there as that
ball got down into the corner and then
it kind of hug the outfield wall and
hamilton had to chase him down back to
the top now and hernandez who fouled out
cesar aligner to left field and this is
off the wall on a hop and high in the
air it is a one out double
for cesar hernandez against mania here
in the third two down it brings up abreu
abreu line shot marte on a hop he did
not catch that it's a live baseball and
hernandez scores abreu drives in the
tying run great swing right here stays
through the ball middle of the field
marte almost makes an amazing play
runner goes and grand all that's a swing
and a miss ball picked up by murphy tags
grandahl a run for the white sox 1-1 tie
here the batter martay
marte with a hit see he got ahead in the
count two and one
i mean he was it was really more than a
coin flip at 507 you knew what was gonna
happen
marty runs pitches outside the throw to
second base
called him out
jeremy riggs the second base umpire
called marty out so this call should be
overturned
and he is safe so the call is overturned
as it should be there are two one with
one out for matt chapman see and the
throw goes into center field watch marty
he's got a chance to keep going and he
is gonna go and he is going to
make it
and matt olson goes all the way around
the third
chapman hits one very high
toward the corner and left hamilton
couple steps in the foul territory he's
got it olson's going to come in to score
easily so two runs in in the inning as
chapman does a nice job getting the ball
airborne and it's a sacrifice fly
a one
line to third romy did he have it and
that's the exchange that should be an
out
two down this is a bullet good job by
romey to knock it down and save his life
that was an absolute rocket off the bat
of sean murphy that exit velocity he's
going to be up there for the hardest hit
today
we go to the six the airs lead 3-1 luis
robert leads it off for the white sox
against mania
get a one-pitch one-out situation here
as chapman staying with it and he's got
it
lines one up the middle face it so jose
abreu has two hits today
manaya's got it fires a second a strike
there and this is gonna be a double play
one four three double play nicely done
by sean manaya new pitcher in the game
mr ryan burr saw him earlier in this
series but he's gonna feature a
four-seamer cutter a slider
got him strike three outside corner
cannon disputes it
one down
to center robert runs it down one two
check swing he went around strike three
off the cutter
one two three inning for ryan first sean
manaya goes out to work the top of the
seventh against the white sox but he is
leading 3-1
hit the other way
and vaughan remains hitless
swing and a miss upstairs got him at 93.
gonzalez
is down on strikes make that nine k's
now for mania three and two
low sinker hamilton scorches it to left
center field
billy's on his way to second and he's
thinking three hamilton for third the
throw is late and the sox have a two out
billy hamilton triple in the seventh
inning it was a misplaced sinker and
billy demolished it
martes coming in right center and he's
got it so mania gives up the triple to
hamilton nothing else and the ending is
over as banaya pounds the mid coming off
the mound and closing out seven strong
against chicago so the ease leading it
three to one over the white sox trying
to win the rubber game of the series and
andrew chaffin's going to come in and
try to close it out
check swing chapman charges he's got it
chapman throws in time one away
[Applause]
could have a play heading over toward
the bullpen and he caught it
he caught it a basket catch
you kidding me mckenna's got to track
this ball make sure that wall is not
going to become a problem there's just a
lot going on here for mark cannon he
throws out the basket and boom
hamilton a little pop-up
olson over
olsen under got it ball game
so andrew chaffin comes in for the ninth
inning he gets his third save of the
year and he saves it
for sean manaya who picks up his ninth
win of the year